Tayla one of the tennessee titans go
blue sir how are you Taylor I'm good so
let's start right off the bat with the
question that I was asking cuz it looks
like well sure
what about pirates Taylor do or do you
have any thoughts on a pirate situation
interesting it's interesting cutting
mics because you're cutting in and out
on us Taylor I mean what's going on with
yeah you got it I mean where are you
driving right now where are you driving
that you come it you couldn't be on a
landline other it doesn't show you're
driving where are you yes science and
technology does not work but I also
don't want you to give you a ticket for
not being hands-free here Taylor no no
I'm all right I'm okay I think we're
gonna be all right boys okay so what do
you think of you know here's the thing I
think that the league should have some
sort of spring league for young
offensive linemen to learn technique and
get up to speed for the speed of the
game because I'm seeing some line play
dreadful because maybe your neck guys
aren't in pads enough across the league
what do you think Taylor because I mean
what do you play you draft the guy in
April and then you put him in a spring
league but that spring league is really
the their first OTAs I mean they haven't
it's hard enough as a rookie coming in
and trying to digest an offensive
playbook you let alone say hey we need
you to go here and start planning if
these guys right away immediately it's a
lot of growing pains when you when you
first come in the NFL but that's kind of
I think that's more like colleges job if
you have guys that are NFL capable you
need to kind of get thumbs up to speed
like hey this is the pass set this is
how you use your hands and a past that
yes this is von Miller he's terrified
it's not just for guys that have just
been drafted it's maybe for some of the
undrafted that that didn't get a gig
didn't get a job that keep them your
curtain
plagued for the amsterdam admirals once
upon a time he's now gonna bust in
Canton
so I'm just saying that there's got to
be you know some help that that's needed
instead of instead like instead of
moving a left guard to right tackle as
the Giants had to do last night maybe
they have a better right tackle the
second and the depth chart because
somebody's had some time getting better
elsewhere oh you know the numbers are so
small and I thought why not
pump up the roster to 63 guys instead of
53 guys and have more of a depth chart
have more competition there possibly hmm
would you be up I don't know I have no
idea you know I'm not a job here to say
but I'm spitballing with you cuz it just
again we may not be talking about this
in october/november because you guys
will have had enough enough you know
snaps under your belts you're figurative
belts but let's move on to the Tennessee
Titans right now here Taylor what what
did happen against the Raiders that you
were able to rectify against the Jaguars
I think I just finished the biggest
thing we went in and they started off as
well the first half of both teams we
knew we had a big you know big thing to
digest they see a lot of stuff to take
care of because the week before the Jags
had ten sacks and so our goal is limit
them to no more than one sack and that's
what we ended up doing there are great
defensive front and I think at the end
of day Mike Mularkey our head coach he
kind of put the old line in the driver
seat and said we're gonna win or lose
based on you guys and we were able to
get the job done this is the matter
consistently doing that week in and week
out is Mari banged up is he healthy best
you can tell me Taylor yeah I don't know
what happened I heard is a ham soon or
something like that
to be honest II I don't know enough to
even talk about it but that's that's one
of the good things about having the
depth that we do it the running back
position I mean we got two other guys
that can really run the ball and Owen
DeMarco is ready to come back you know
he's gonna take know your Bluetooth
kicked in again man your Justin on it
did what is happening I can hear you
yeah we're good we're good just stick
with it stick with the Bluetooth and
just stay right there I'm not I wasn't
even messing with it so we I I'm right
now my truck's doing whatever it was
it's technology
it's ty it's alive
trucks alive we'll call it maize and
Bluetooth retailer the want of the
Tennessee Titans thanks so much here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so now you it's
interesting how you said to telling
offensive linemen young offensive
linemen this is what this technique is
that's what that one that's Von Miller
he's scary
here come the Seattle Seahawks this
weekend there's a lot of scary guys to
use that phrase what what are you
thinking about prior to this big matchup
between you and Seattle in your house
this weekend yeah those guys they can
always surpass her I think that's what
that deep of the fun is built on is just
trying to get to the quarterback get to
the quarterback gets the quarterback and
the best the best way to stop a team
from being the quarterback is running
the ball well if you can run the ball
well and get to certain manageable then
we should be able to keep them at bay
and everything but you know our office
line
I feel like we're really cooking right
now everybody's on the same page it's a
really good group of guys as you've seen
in the offseason we do hang out we we
get after pretty good and I think you
know it's a work hard play hard
mentality with the boys and I look
pretty good about it well I gotta be
honest with you if somebody who drafted
Marcus Mariota and my fantasy league you
get me concerned talking about running
this much Taylor what about the passing
game here with your guy I think we had a
good a really good game have some great
throws we have some good running game
towards the end the game going so I
think I think you're in for a treat I
think this will be a good game for
anybody that wants to watch it
okay what about celebrations for the
offensive line and the relaxed
celebration rules we saw 1o linemen I
forget who it was for the Atlanta
Falcons create a hoop through which
Devonta Freeman shot a free throw is
there anything going on there with you
Taylor and the rest of your team to go
on that hoop sing no it's Angela b-tree
who also play for the Tennessee Titans
when I first got here yep
and if you notice Freeman when he shot
it Andy had to move his hoop to make
sure the shot went in so you know for me
if I was the hoop I mean you got to play
the who but who doesn't move in the real
life
are you saying Mari or or Henry
attempting it withdraw iron is what
you're saying what is there good now you
understand this not allowed to use props
so catfish cannot cannot happen
Taylor be careful in here it's just a
fine choreographed anything yet but hang
if the time ever comes right we'll be
prepared we'll be prepared as hopefully
your eyes are on it reg okay
now before I let you go with you and
your Bluetooth in your truck into that
Tennessee afternoon I am concerned to
say the least about Michigan at Purdue
this weekend based on what I've seen
over the last couple of weeks from from
our alma mater at home three you know is
three you know I don't see any pictures
in the in the and the standings or the
rankings
what's say you Taylor about what you've
seen from Michigan football over the
first three weeks going in Purdue I
think it's hard hard to evaluate playing
air force because the office they run
it's just that though it's a funky deal
it's hit and miss so unless you're
breezes at quarterback okay are you
speaking to any of the old linemen and
I'll tell you I'm gonna contact
relationships with them most of the guys
that I play with her either now in the
NFL or moved on and see the real world
okay but for me I think Mason Cole is
one office lemon I actually hosted him
on his visit okay
and I think he plays out the saltiness
he'll actually set the record for most
stores that have any office lemon in the
history of the University of Michigan
hmm okay so
you you'd like look I love what I'm
seeing from the team I saw what out of
Florida last couple weeks it was it was
up and down and you know what it's like
going on the road in the Big Ten and
Purdue just wants to put a maize and
blue Pelt on the wall and I know Jim
knows that but I appreciate your
confidence I'll take it you know they're
they're better they have new uniforms a
new sense of confidence whatever but at
the end of the day I just think if
anything comes down to coaching and I
think we have that no got it
well you don't have to say that twice to
me all right Taylor thanks for the call
appreciate it good luck against Seattle
stay in touch we'll chat down the line
okay you guys that's terrible on a Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience isn't it amazing you can
download an app with your thumbprint you
should download our app with your
thumbprint